[Music] [Applause] [Music] oh
[Music]
starting goal tenders brought to you by Kelloggs
the best to you each morning Rick tabarra gets
the call starting for the fourth time in the
last five games for the Calgary Flames uh the
record doesn't do any favors but you know he
hasn't played all that badly considering the
way things have gone for the team Mike RoR at
the other end a 13 and two during his career
against the Calgary Flames with a 4.1 two goals
against [Music] average Rangers penalty killing
unit is leech and bab with Graves and Messier
that shot kicked Away by rer he recovers Theo
flurry number 14 up front with Paul Cruz number 12
Ronnie Stern number 22 Flames moving again Rangers
penalty killing is tailed off after a fast start
theyve given up Power Play Goals in each of their
last eight games Presley and sunstrom have come
on with sus son and Driver save made by rer on
the first shot to the rebound neander number 92
beat to driver making his first appearance as a
New York Ranger wearing number 33 Puck kept in
by neander number 92 former Hartford wher he's
on with dermont tto number 13 and Pavel forgea
number 18 and a save by rer he's made a couple
of real good ones he's focused once again and
very balanced extremely well balanced after
he's made the save played along the boards B the
point recently came over from Colorado this shot
by Dean Evon is a save by RoR Messier has come on
he's down low the pass is to robai in the corner
do is there now litster with a quick shot save
made by good play Mike Sullivan with good speed
of Boston University products out there Lee your
shot deflected wide Trent Yanni number eight is
on with James Patrick the O flurry number 14 Mike
Sullivan number 32 and Stern for his trouble will
stay out there now for the power power play where
he starts off in the right wing so a man Advantage
for the Calgary Flames their second power play
of the hockey game 0 and the Flames had a few
shots during the first power play before it was
ended Puck comes up ahead to stern Stern dropping
it back for Patrick back to Howley shoots that
one's tipped and Wobbles its way wide flurry
just hanging back from The Fray he'll come in
to pick it up here's Hy dander back for Howley
and Chason turns and shoots saved by RoR through
traffic here's tto missed the net back pass to
Howley tto to Howley 5 seconds in the power play
K off holding in the corner neander now Howley
for tgef he shoots save by RoR oh baby he had
a great chance on the last power play that the
Flames had as well pavell sty there by Mike RoR
he could have had two goals in this hockey game
thus far but instead Mike RoR has been the star
watch Tav he's parked out to the left of RoR RoR
went down but then look his he to all he had
to do was put it upstairs and instead I think
he panicked right here he had good possession the
puck and look at he had all the time in the world
there wasn't a ranger that was even close until
well after the time that he had shot the puck
and then good old [Music] samelson Baro taken
away by flurry good play flurry moves in flurry
shoots High here's Cruz he gets it ahead Stern
coming in on the right hand side Stern in front
scores Ronnie Stern gives the Flames a
one- nothing [Applause] lead 22 he Stern
scored Saturday night against Vancouver
and tonight he gets his team on the board
[Applause] First Watch the Flames they broke right
out of their end and they had full possession of
it you see that the Rangers baboom tried to stand
up but he wasn't able to do so or do much about
it Stern just ended up taking that puck from H
and put it into the empty side nice break out
by the Flames but not such a nice defensive job
by the New York Rangers that tended to watch the
Calgary [Music] Flames on the board Messier back
of the net curling around but the puck doesn't
come to him this is Cruz long shot that one what
a flint and RoR will hang on to it in his 12th
season in the NHL a former first round pick of
the Rangers TOA Cuts in gets the shot off and a
save by R he's had a great game to this point TOA
that's got to be three or four scoring chances on
his own he's back in the net now kovalev trying
to center it tabaracci knocked it away here's
periro to kovalev in front of the net roai was
there but had lots of company 1334 to go second
period I'm Paul romanu along with Gary green at
Madison Square Garden great to have you with us
tonight the only NHL game puck comes back lster
shoots one in wide and from the other point low
of a shot twin cannons each took a shot casmer was
a draft pick of the Minnesota North Stars he went
went to Hartford was traded to Hartford for Dean
Evon now their teammates with the Calgary play 27
years of age Dan kmer kmer for interference at
642 Rangers third power play the roll for two
driving shoot safe Messier scores for Messier
it's a power play goal remember the Adam Graves
hit a couple of minutes ago that's what got the
Rangers going bad move by the Flames taking the
penalty Tesmer just gave the new New York Rangers
the opportunity to overcome a bad power play they
had previously Bruce driver smart offensive player
he just picked up that Puck and diagonally passed
that puck all the way through the slot Messier
with a sharp eye picked the net where there was
lots of room goal number six on the year for
Mark Messier going to the front of the net roai
up there too roai from the corner get it back
putt ripped wide of the net by baboom had time
to wind it up tarach is going to hang on to it
good pass from robai down here now watch right
in the middle of your screen there there's
baboom though now watch there's nobody out
there bab boom's got all the time in the world
he shot wide but what a big blasting shot of
his actually when he had that much time should
have been able to hit the net at least here's
Chase it back baboom takes a hit he thought it
was icing he thought it was icing he let up did
he Pay Here's R trying to break down he's hooked
by Hosley breaks free R going to the neck and a
save by tarachi good effort by B good effort that
the quickest I've seen him skate as a ranger burb
took right off he got that pass up the middle
you see Howley hooking him from behind that
slowed him down enough that Chason may have
been able to catch him but you can see that
Chason ended up diving and just throwing verbi
off balance of anything I think Howley should
have been given a penalty though back in the
neutral zone G spins around samelson Samuelson
trying to catch up around the net for gab he's
pressed by grave centering pass in front tacom
was taken down by samelson back the other way two
onone Messier Eng Graves grav shoots save tabarra
the rebound is loose and play by the flame what
a play at both [Music] ends now it's Cruz number
12 with it samelson coming back both teams being
very cautious is here change for the flame shot
by Missi score through the legs of Rick tabaki
with a big Slap Shot goal number 499 for Martin
[Applause] Messier Messier with his second
and the Rangers leaded two to one plays like
that shots like that will make the
Rangers job easier in February when
it comes that time there's the turnover the
transition play and you can see that Calgary
were on a line change that whole left wing
Corridor was wide open Messier had forever
to wind up but from that far out no way
tabarra should have blown that [Applause]
one roll number seven of the year for Messier and
is second of this [Music] game taking a penalty
now seier lifts the team with the go-ahead goal
the Rangers draw a power play they have the lead
for the first time 2 to one Messier from samelson
at 418 and Dan kmer goes into the Penalty Box
again 45 seconds left in the man Advantage Messier
across leech to the net leech against aapsky
Graves takes over raer out try score Adam Graves
it's a power play goal and the Rangers are Up 3
to [Applause] one two good goals for the Rangers
two bad goals for the Calgary Flames leech was up
in the play as usual watch Graves though Graves
came in took the puck and then just a little wrap
around [Applause] eighth goal Corner Pocket
post goenda power play goal Graves gets it my
apologies to Mark Flames come in and that shot
stopped by RoR Jason able to clear out to Mike
Sullivan Sullivan with a lead to flurry flurry
plays it toward the net RoR covers up and gets a
whistle 499 didn't shut the door on the five hole
tab awfully close to 500 hey maybe Glen sather
being in the building uh put a little spark there
here's RoR with a great save RoR was down but
there was room up [Music] top watch this neander
heads to the net now watch he's got that puck on
his backand he tried to get the first shot away
and then Tred to get his rebound and you could
see where RoR was positioned he was down and out
as neander got in behind Bruce driver Messier back
checking making sure neander didn't get much of a
rebound chance as Howley kept the play alive and
he does here again Howley moving away shooting
back RoR makes the same and PPS it away from
[Music] flurry here's McCarthy trying to come out
of The Fray with the puck off
the draw Howley shoot scores
Howley fired it in it may have been tipped on
the way through but it's 32 the Flames pulled
it within one surprised everyone everyone in the
building everyone up here watch Howley he just
gets that puck now watch he's even off balance he
just slides that puck he was back leaning on his
left leg and it went right in the corner watch
again Howley he's got all of his weight on his
left foot he's leaning to his left arm obviously
and just fires the puck towards the net and Le
she takes him out driver touch pass Graves to
Messier he shoots he scores Mark Messier number
500 and it's a hatrick what a night for Mark
Messier and the hats are starting to litter
the ice the ranger players know exactly what it
means the bench is standing oh do they love their
captain and he's leading them tonight 500 NHL
go for the great Mark Messier what a performance
Mark Messier takes over I think the Rangers
in this situation know what it means to their
Captain they have not left the bench as it's not
within the rules the Rangers with their tradition
and the way they deal with these things which is
a lot of class they will have something planned
for Mark Messier to celebrate the 500th goal of
his NHL career is no wonderful to know that Glen
s there's here yeah his former coach look at that
Bon Evon nobody deserves it more than this guy he
lives eats Breeze hockey it's the Jersey doubles
in the playoffs the last regular season hat trick
was 1992 all against New Jersey you know this is
a great moment in sports you just don't see it
this is one of maybe the greatest team player
you'll ever find for leadership his his the
quality in which he looks at hockey the way he
carries himself with the media the way the way
he carries himself off the ice with hospitals
and helping Charities that's why people fall in
love with him and believe me Sam he appreciates
what these people are doing right here right now
in the way that they're reacting to his night
with his 500th goal and a big he appreciates
it in the context of a game it's a big goal with
Calgary coming on Messier gives the Rangers the
two-goal lead again Le that's what Hartford said
when they hired him so they got him quickly into
the organization next thing you know he's there
Patrick shoots save RoR came way out doesn't
know where the puck is it's all the way out by
the Blue Line blurry shoots and RoR makes the
save zabski shoots a deflection hit the side
out of the net galary now getting into loose
pucks here ande 10 to go as flurry GS the Rangers
Zone shoots and a save by rer for the draw one by
the point back to Theo flurry try to play toward
the N it was blocked by sunstrom Messier Graves
and sunstrom sunstrom seeing a lot of important
defensive time late in the game rra around try
save by RoR another shot was blocked ttop behind
the net Ricker didn't know where the puck was he
stayed down for a long time here's tto's pass
block leech tries to move it does to Graves he
lifts it clear bouncing Puck flurry knocked
away Messi a shot for an empty net was block
and a whistle for offside oh just about just
about you know what I mean and for those of
you who read those uh silly stories last week
about the trade with St Louis forget about it
never going to happen Messi a night the Rangers
win 4 to2 Messier with a hattick to reach the 500
goal Mar Mark a memorable evening in the great
career of Mark Messier remember that that'll be
the trivia name who was the goalie when Mark
scored his 50th Rick tabarra the Rangers 500
I mean pardon me excuse me Rangers win their
eighth game of the season as they go 85 and
one Mike rler picks up his fourth win of the
Season he is 45 and0 and what a special night
for